now that their sound manager is
initialized the next thing we need to
take care of is actually loading our
sound effects so that they're ready to
play and a way the Audio API is similar
to the image loading process that we use
for canvas we only load images
asynchronously and for essentially the
same reasons so what we're going to do
is check if the sound has already been
loaded and if it is we call our callback
function if it's not we kick off a load
in the form of an XML HTTP request and
then assign the callback function for
once the load has completed finally
we're going to return to actual clip
data either way now here's some skeleton
code to help you get up and running we'd
like you to do is to fill in the code so
that performs the asynchronous loading
that I just described